and the wedding took place in an old
swingers den the wedding was a the
wedding took place in this old swingers
place where swingers used to do you know
sex I guess in adult activities and
swingers I know in LA there's some
pretty intense swinger parties I've
heard about him you know and I've
actually been invited to some and I
haven't gone yet because I'm not going
because my back's pretty hairy and I'm
not taking a hairy back to a damn
swingers event I just do not have that
kind of confidence you know in my butt
gets kind of hairy too and I'm not
taking a hairy ass into a swingers thing
so I need to get probably you know waxed
up and maybe do some you know some some
different leg exercises and some reverse
leg curls and stuff before him to go to
a swingers thing but I wouldn't mind
checking it out sometime one time I was
in Lake of the Ozarks Missouri and that
is swear country you know that's a good
place to taste another man's wife or you
noted you know really a spray-out on
some you know local spouse it's not
yours you know where to be wild and we
went there me and this man this other
man we went there we were just comedians
you know we just show up and we're
supposed to stay at Lake of the Ozarks
for one night so we check into the hotel
because we're doing a comedy show there
so we check in at the hotel we always
stay at right and he's the feature I'm
the headliner we're not together we're
just friends [ __ ] honestly me and the
student didn't even know each other
we just know we're both comedians and we
both drove down from the airport in
Columbia Missouri we get there we get to
the front desk the guy at the front desk
goes are you guys girls only boys only
or boys and girls only and I'm thinking
but what the [ __ ] is the third option
for like you know first I'm like what's
going on you know but then I'm like
what's the third what is the third
option even and then we realize that
it's a swingers convention it's taken
over the hotel for the weekend and it's
a beautiful little resort hotel it's
right on the water
you know it's a nice place to probably
you know be by yourself or you know I
guess be with somebody else's spouse or
whatever but then we start seeing people
just bring it in all these little
at hotels and motels they got the
trolleys where you put all your goods on
them you wheel them up to your room
you know and a lot of you know a lot of
people bring their own food and
everything and these people were
bringing everything dude I mean you
would see like a like a like a like a
everything was from you know Costco or
one of those univers Kirkland
like Kirkland brand you know that Big
Bird like bulk Kirkland brand you know
Rice Krispies Kirkland brand lubricant
Kirkland brand like pool toys you know
they had everything and these people
none of them to me were visually
appealing right that were they weren't
appealing to me but it was swingers
right and then you saw they had this one
lady was bringing in the black guy and
you could tell he was the [ __ ] hammer
you know you could tell this dude was
flying he might have gotten paid to come
here and perform you know he was that
dark dagger you know that air that air
that air meat you know that there was
FedEx and around the [ __ ] country
probably to come in and just satisfy the
regional uh you know that regional [ __ ]
you feel me so this dude's hitting the
Airways and probably just you know just
straight-up drilling drilling drilling
in different areas around the countries
popping off you know he's sprouting out
you know he's rooting down and uh and
some local you know and local wives you
could already see like these guys
probably had posters you know that all
the white the white man we're gonna be
like go get him black guy you know like
Terrence forever you know [ __ ] like that
cuz this dude was about to pop off on
some local wives and but you had people
bust you know just people with Wheat
Thins and all kinds of big snacks and
I'll tell you this man I wasn't into it
at all until I'm not even joking till I
saw the Wheat Thins
I love Wheat Thins man I don't know who
did Wheat Thins or Pringles but they
they [ __ ] killed it now those are
kind of snacks that would make me want
to be at a swingers thing you know if
you follow me I don't know if I'm you
know I don't
Carroll who I land in if they got a bowl
of Wheat Thins or Pringles next to their
orifice or you know a little side tray
next to the body dude dude dude dude
dude you know what I'm saying
put a uh put some floaties on daddy's
dick because I'm going in you feel me
because I will I will I will I will
perform if there is a side item of Wheat
Thins or a Pringles you know that's
that's a feast
that's a feast for me in my libido that
keeps me up but uh but anyway this place
they're like they're like oh if you guys
aren't here with the conference then you
can't be here with the swingers
convention and we're like what the [ __ ]
you know like we have to be here you
know there was just a mistake they
booked us at the wrong place but I'm
also like what the [ __ ] still does girls
and boys only like that's not even I
guess that means you're open for
whatever I guess it does mean something
actually but but anyhow everybody gets a
bracelet he said you can't have it you
can't have a bracelet you can't
participate in any activities but if you
want to come down and watch the bingo
night
you can like well you know whatever you
know we're just we're just gonna be here
for one night so we go to our comedy
show we get back to we have a couple of
beers at the place at the bar the comedy
spot we get back to the hotel and we're
like do we got a/c you know we got to go
over the mountain you know to see what
he could see cuz that's what the bear
did you know some time you got to be out
there you got to be a baby bear you know
sometime if you smell honey you can't
just sit on your hands if you smell
honey you can't sit on your hands
because you're not gonna get anything
you're not gonna get any sweetener in
your mouth if you just sitting on your
paws are you some of them you gotta
stand up and open your mouth and follow
your nose at the same time if you want
to land your face and some of that
[ __ ] local sweetener so we got up you
know and we start walking around and
peeking downstairs and downstairs they
are doing
the biggest game of what is it with the
red and the blue and the yellow it's
like the handprint and foot and you
spend the dial G buzz you know what I'm
talking about they're doing the biggest
game of that I've ever seen there's like
40 boards hooked together there's like
in the middle there's nineteen people
who are no longer playing the game
accurately right there's an old person
spinning there's one woman who is still
playing the game right
still playing like you know right hand B
or whatever it is a right hand green and
then there's nineteen people in the
middle just I mean I don't even know
what to say they were doing I don't know
if they were some of it was sex it was
in the very middle there was something
vibrating in there that was just going
off and that could have been the hammer
you know that could have been the dark
artist down there you know that could
have been you know diandra or whoever
they had brought the hammer you know
that guy could have been just Dewalt you
know that could have been Dewalt
or Stahl you know or Black & Decker
whoever it was that fella was popping
off down there you could just see and
that's where the heat was coming out of
and everybody else was just riding off
the vibes and there was a lot of just
puffy adults a lot of seniors a lot of
people in their 60s and you know and
even 70s you know a lot of a lot of that
you know Tampa cleavage where you see a
lot of women have that tan right in the
middle of their breasts but it looks
like they're probably gonna get cancer
they're you know kind of that San
Andreas Fault you know you can kind of
see that they had a lot of some gold
chains you know a lot of bad gold a lot
of bad local gold and then so then we we
we we peak and then we scoot right we
open the elevator we're think I'm going
to go up the elevator man that thing was
just a vertical [ __ ] trolley that
elevator was stacked smelled like oh man
somebody smelled like somebody had left
Chinese food in there
trunk overnight and if you ever done
that or not
because it's kind of still got a little
bit of a sweet smell to it but you know
that if you eat it it'll uh it'll upset
your stomach you know it'll make a knees
weak if you eat any of it and that was
the smell that was inside of that of
that elevator at that swingers
convention that we were not supposed to
be at in the first place but hey that's
one of the gifts of the industry that's
one of the gifts of comedy you know to
end up in environments like that good
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one